I mean my mom always said if you have
the ability of the responsibility if you
can than you must like you can just that
work alone will save millions of dogs
lives yep and it's literal you just
sitting with the camera your phone and
pressing record that's it
yeah no fancy anything intro extra none
of that yeah just you and the phone talk
I'm Troy Troy Tappan I've been a
professional dog trainer for like 21
years since 1997 I do things differently
you know my my whole what's your
approach is different I want people to
enjoy the full experience of of these
incredible animals yeah and the experts
over 15,000 years you know that the best
that we've come up with is sit stay lie
down heal and come you know go pee pee
on a pee pad the almighty treat and for
me it's never been about limiting the
experience what I loved about you was
when we got Timo I grew up with dogs my
whole life but I haven't had a dog my
own dog for a while and a puppy for a
long time I thought okay good to get
some reinforcements to just remind
myself of how it works and shook at the
path yeah and the very first question
you asked me when you came over was how
do you see the dog fit into your life
like tell me about your ideal life and
how the dog fits in and then we're gonna
we're gonna make that happen
yeah like I like this guy yeah it's
different yeah you should have your
dream guy like this approach yeah you
know I put in the time I put in the
hours
I built a solid reputation the money
doesn't show it doesn't show the efforts
and because you're still doing
one-on-one yeah I mean yeah and it's
hard to it's hard to teach somebody else
to do what I do so you you either go
when you are the best of what you do
service based business you either go
super high-end and now instead of
charging whatever an hour now you charge
in a thousand dollars an hour right
yeah that's actually what I've found is
you know if I if I limit my experience
to what's out there in terms of dog
training it's a numbers game you know
massive amounts of clients limited
amount of hours that I can work and and
the money doesn't show well so you
either keep scaling up and keep bumping
up your pricing yeah and so that cuts
off some people from working with you
yeah but you keep you get known in the
inner circles as the guy to go with to
build to create the ideal life with your
dog yeah just like personal trainers
like they start off servicing everybody
and then if you are actually good you
start working with the politicians and
the CEOs and then you're charging a lot
more per hour right then you would if
you're just targeting Joe Blow yeah so
that could make you if you're if you're
like a really good service based
business you could you could be a solo
person making two three hundred thousand
a year just by you being by yourself and
targeting high-income people who really
value the expertise yeah that's one path
the other path of the Gil mass so that
path does not allow for you to get your
message out there yeah you're behind the
scenes you're known you know in the
inner circles of people but if you want
to fundamentally shift how people think
about your industry yeah and that's
really that's one of the things that's
really important to me moving beyond the
five yeah he said commands you know I
mean there's with all respect I mean
there's there's three-year-olds on
YouTube that couldn't get a dog to you
know skateboard they can do they can do
it all but for me what's important in in
my own life is to you know when I look
at my own my own puppy I have a
one-year-old Old English bulldog I know
he's a bulldog and that one he's not
fully mature and he's supposed to be
goofy you know he's supposed to be
combative I know all of these things I
want him to be you know a protector of
the home when I when I shut the lights
off at night and the sweetest thing with
with me and the family and future
grandkids right
and you can have it all and it's not
about you-know-what cookie is gonna make
him sit because quite frankly if he
never sits a day in his life I don't
care because the the benefit in in that
relationship
I mean you if you if you drill down even
to the fact that these animals can
recognize their own mate and if you just
use something as simple as that to
develop this trust build this
relationship there's so many other
aspects that you can teach and learn and
and and have so why limit the experience
I think you just need to create content
yeah
not listen not everybody's gonna take
that approach not over is gonna agree
with you yeah some people say I just
want my dog to know how these do these
five things okay yeah but there's gonna
be a lot of people who say oh this is I
didn't even know this is possible yeah
yeah and you know that's if there's a
category that I want to fall into is is
is not a dog trainer my tuning fork
never moves if someone calls me a dog
trainer okay if they call me a teacher
okay that turns me on
okay because you know for for 21 years
I've I've gone into different homes
people of different backgrounds children
with you know isms and syndromes and all
kinds of things and it could be a brand
new puppy it could be a rescue dog it
could be aggression issues I mean the
amount of situations that I've that I've
had to deal with are our countless what
when it when it comes to the whole
teaching aspect dogs have have opened
the way for for families to come
together and that for me that's I got
really emotional you know one of my best
experiences was a young boy he was five
he was autistic
and he wouldn't settle down he was
banging on the flat-screen TV
they brought me in for the dog obviously
that was being aggressive and I spoke to
the young boy I asked him if he wanted
to play a game we ended up getting him
to sit down and fold his fingers that
was part of the game okay and I looked
over in his dad I had tears streaming
down and he said five professionals have
not been able to get that boy to sit
down okay and you know long story short
seven or eight years later I think was
eight years later the family dynamic had
changed dad brought me in to the new
dynamic and picked up this young boy
brought him over and the first thing out
of his mouth was Troy I remember what
you taught me no I thought me to do this
and for me I mean that's that's the
stuff that turns me but is that what you
want to do work with kids and families
yeah I want to be a teacher it's higher
of what trust respect nature's laws
those are things that that that I want
to teach we're so important for
marketing right where it's important to
communicate yeah to get your message out
there yeah it's a struggle with the
words that is the only thing that's
holding you back yeah that's that's
exactly it yeah so something around
still you got an ex for a reason let's
have Phil that reason then the paragraph
you know everything in nature is
connected yep raising a dog is the same
as reason appliances the same as raising
a kid if you understand the basic
elements of how nature works right hi
I'm Troy I'm a freak right I understand
nature right this is what I'm great at
right and then I'm gonna leave but I'm a
freak I love that yeah well this is your
entire website let's launch your site
yes literally your entire website word
for word yeah right yeah
to to fulfill the purpose of
whatever your plant child animal you
have yeah you need to understand three
basic things trust respect laws of
nature
instagrams the fastest way to grow you
to was a more sustainable way to grow
it's I think a combination of you making
videos sharing your philosophy and then
doing the work so how do I share those
philosophies without giving away the
secrets but they can't do it you're free
whatever whatever you told like whatever
you say in the video I'm gonna try to do
it it's not an instructional like here's
how to do what I do thank you yeah that
yeah cuz I can't do it
right yeah you know what I run up
against is and this is my own mindset of
promoting myself in those video clips
the tendency is to go grab the money
shot hit the soundbite and I just want
to be freakishly me great so do that
I mean sound bites are good for
communication so if you're making a
video dealing with an autistic child to
have a sound bite that grab somebody
just like the headline of your website
right it's a good marketing skill to
learn but you don't have to have a hard
sales pitch you don't have to go at the
end hey and if you have an autistic
child call me I'm Troy right I'll make
your life better the distinction yeah
right yeah but if you kept producing
content that showcased your expertise
people will write to you and say hey
Troy can you happen with this right hey
char can I hire you to do this yeah I
tried you want to speak at my event yeah
like all of my speaking gigs my book
deals all that stuff comes from the
YouTube channel right I talked to a lot
of people who who have made it in the
old world like in the in the book
writing world
you know David Bach no it's a money guy
sold seven million books had him on my
channel and like nobody knows who he was
right he's just not making content right
she's not relevant into places that you
need to be relevant in right right oui
je veux hammer-on who's Tony Robbins
marketing mentor people - they know who
was right this is not creating content
right and so you got all these genius
talented people who have no awareness
and then other people who are building a
huge name for themselves on Instagram
and YouTube and getting hired to go do
speaking gigs we're just doing the same
five things about the dogs the five
rules sit whatever right right yeah
they're taking hacks of yeah right yeah
100% but they're just better marketers
right with less experience right so my
I'm a great marketer I need to boost up
my experience is what I'm doing is I've
been doing for the past X number of
years but I'm sad when I passed people
who are think are more talented than I
am just because they just weren't great
at marketing for you I would start with
organic content on Instagram short like
one-minute videos yeah and I would mix
it between
and and the great part about it is it's
low production quality right you need to
have a videographer there with you all
the time right you filming from your
phone right just great yeah because
they're coming to you you're a thought
leader they're not coming to you for
fitness tips or like fashion or whatever
right you can teach me how you think
right so did not come to you because
your videos look like Steven Spielberg
produced some they're coming to you
because they got their dog for a reason
and they want fulfill that reason right
so sharing your philosophy and then
showing me how you do it so here's my
Bulldog I don't care if you learn send
us it here's what I want him to do right
I want him to be able to do X and then
you make another video so you pick one
thing per video one key message yep per
video and then that's the video yeah and
then you make another one the next day
and another one the next day you're
going for a walk with your daughter
right and we've been doing this since
she was five years old and maybe she
says something right say yeah I mean
walks my dad earth or the gym yeah he's
a freak love that love right yeah love
that right yeah I know you've involved
your daughter and like pictures and
stuff in Instagram but but beyond just
looking at your life I want to learn
something right what are we gonna learn
from it right and so if you're walking
with your daughter in the park maybe
that's a weekly series right like you
still walk I mean I know she's a nut and
she's older now but you guys still walk
regularly and every week every week yeah
great so it's a weekly video now in the
park yeah your daughter new message
yeah yeah right it's happening yeah
that's brilliant I love that so that
that's and it's meant to be low
production quality a low budget it's you
on your phone i recording the video you
have one minute on instagram to record a
video rice and so the first couple times
you may suck or run out of time or
stumble and whatever but yeah you work
on it you get better yeah so that's
that's one series great so every every
Saturday you're gonna post a video with
your daughter talking about
parenting right and you can give me
ideas for what questions to ask on the
walk right or some other philosophies
it's like walk in the park is one thing
every week I'm sure you have lots of
other ideas yeah talk about each one of
those but one one message per video
right right like okay trust how do you
build trust with your with your kid
right here's one exercise to do right
right if you see them freaking out and
smashing the TV like just go there and
say hey do you want to play a game right
the thing is the difficult part is for
you it's just so natural it's being able
to see huh like the stuff that I do is
kind of weird
yeah it's freakish right it's a freakish
yeah yeah so I need to be able to
communicate that I need to pull out and
say what what am i doing now that's
pretty freakish yeah and then share that
yeah is for an outsider they don't know
what's happening right see if they
explain what I'm looking at right cuz
even just seeing you do it I don't I
don't understand all the mechanics of
what's happening right even like before
you know Christina comes up maybe maybe
you're like I might see you petting her
face but maybe before that you've
already done ten steps that I'm not
maybe you just took a deep breath in
right if you've grounded yourself into
the floor like I don't know I'm making
Safa no no no no you're paying on and
after you like ten subconscious steps
that for you is just boom boom boom yeah
and then all I see is how come she's
going to him and Mike right right and
then I go on like try to back yes are
gonna work yeah yeah well got explained
welcome to my world
right yeah so you gotta codify it you
gotta explain yeah what it is that you
do and this mean that I can just do it
now expand that you're a freak right I
understand that this is a natural gift
that you have and then I want to hire
you and I want to I'm gonna I want you
to come speak in my conferences and
events right right right
teach me to think like you think so
you've been walking into here with doing
this event awesome you got cameras
everywhere getting set up you know like
what are you what do you think of when
you're walking in what are you what are
you right there for you know what's your
what's your mind doing meditation before
do you you know I don't know yeah you do
yeah the freakish stuff that you do yeah
and you may even need you may even need
your daughter to help call smother that
out it's like that you know what like
yeah this is why you're a freak yeah
yeah yeah yeah you want to hear the song
in the radio and you set it out loud and
the next song in the radio is that song
on the radio so high but how do you then
how do you teach me something from that
beyond just beyond just well Troy is a
freak yep teach me what teach me why
yeah yeah I can find I can find the
lessons in there yeah yeah and then you
apply the teach series so you have your
Bulldog series once a week about the hug
to you got your daughter series once a
week about parenting and then what else
maybe there's just a chore a rant of the
week right where's like here's a problem
with the dog trainers I love them
they're great ends in tension but
they're only focused on the five things
right I think that's wrong I think you
need right this is like just philosophy
yep
philosophy once a week yep and it's
literal you just sitting with the camera
yeah your phone and pressing record
that's it yeah no fancy anything
intro extra none of that yeah just you
and the phone talking I for a long time
I thought of following you know so maybe
part of this weekly series is I thought
of following one dog through like the
Truman Show
okay kind of idea you know K this is
where we started you know this is where
we are this week this is a how long a
shot about that Anthony and I'm like
cousin brother Anthony we got to push
this guy a little bit harder right the
screws Anthony yeah that that's a that's
a brand new 15 16 year idea Wow
yeah okay so it's time to do it yeah
maybe and maybe maybe it doesn't work
right but you need to scratch the itch
just to know right so it's not another
15 years before you try it right and now
it's it's easy to do it like 15 years
ago you'd have to have a camera and
following them around
editing and all that and then where do
you even post it there's no YouTube
right right where now you can you can
post it thanks a gram yeah should do it
your dog or a client's dog or what yeah
either one great I mean even if you say
as a maybe you take one client and it's
free right you're gonna work with them
for six months
yeah but the caveat is you're gonna film
every week of progress right like you
see a dog walk with like eight dogs and
like yanking them all over the place
okay yeah okay like go help some person
yeah okay I got some suggestions yeah
I'm always I'm always shy about that no
you already have the answer
trust respect and lots of nature right
how do you deal with how do you deal
with that dog walker he'll trust respect
and laws of nature right it's the same
thing as working with a crazy dog or her
crazy kid smashing TVs right I guess
doubt yeah yeah that Walker yeah just
got to be freakish new Troy and it's
still nature it's all nature yep great
yeah if you can help an elephant you can
help this dog walker struggling with
ethics and then you start attracting
people who love that right right and and
you can use hash tags a switch on
Instagram like dogs of Instagram and
there's a lot of this is a huge dog
culture yeah but for all of them for
parenting for cats all that stuff
there's there's a huge culture Instagram
yeah and some people will see that and
say holy cow this guy's crazy it's
awesome yeah I want more Troy my life
right yeah
and maybe that's only 10 percent of dog
owners yeah awesome
and as you get better and on the under
communication maybe that expansive like
25 percent of dog owners but now there's
a natural alternative to what most
people are putting it just feels good
you open my mind like when you came in
right yeah I was not on my radar yeah I
didn't know it existed yeah no this is
my tuning fork is like boom I know but
now you need to get it out yeah yeah and
you have a responsibility to get it out
yeah thanks
right no you're right I mean my mom
always said if you have the ability of
the responsibility if you can then you
must right
like you can just that work alone will
save millions of dogs lives like they're
putting their dog down because they have
an issue that's that you could easily
solve yeah or just educating them right
yeah so that that's how that like that
then that starts to weigh on me right
it's like okay now it's my
responsibility I have to go up and do it
right even though some people want to
agree with it even though traditional
dog trainers we like the sky's psycho
like don't listen to his advice yeah
great
Co man thanks for coming in thank you
thank you I'm pumped for you man yeah
this is great super fun if you want to
get coached by me one-on-one to help you
build your brain and make money as a
thought leader check out my next
workshop in Toronto the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there